I'm not wearing any pants because I know
that I'm about to crap them am i we are
now your son of a [ __ ] I'll kill the
door looks fragile locked something is
happening with the door I'm free Wow are
you a lumberjack holy balls look at you
you're so big and strong Oh kill me bro
go kill me bro cheese cheese cheese no
I'm gonna supersets cheese mmm I like me
some cheese I'm not going that way screw
you by God you son of a [ __ ] you said
there'd be cheese okay can you put that
down now that would be lovely if you can
put that down thank you who's Bobby ha
ha you're stuck ha ha ha you're not
stuck
some say how's that baby doing
hey man better calm the baby common why
I was helping your baby who's my baby
I'm irresistible even to the monster
ladies they all want a piece of
markiplier I know
oh no no no no no no no no no no no no
no there's something behind here there
seems to be some strange stack of boxes
tell me this was on the base with the
whole time I know I talked kind of
spastically when I'm in a high-stress
situation I'm trying
hey you son of [ __ ] did I stop it
what's all this weirdness hey kid what
to do on there hi you're still
disturbing I've made a loop wanna say
what I don't know what's going on so I'm
just gonna let him kill me ah my body is
ready oh I need a key
Oh key how conveniently play wait
somebody's alright popcorn no reason to
panic
that's not cool breath no not cool bruh
excuse me can you turn the lights back
on and I have no Papa Papa found boots
oh I'm gonna die
what's a bush doing in here yeah I don't
have a tolerance for any sort of bull
from you ha ha yeah ah holy balls you're
faster now but now you're not supposed
to be faster why are you bastard
good game crashed all right come in boom
double for your defense
Oh made you think twice about that one
yeah that's right get back run off you
cannot conquer this I am too pro hey it
worked
seriously nice breakdancing man you've
really been back to signal oh you want
another taste
oh yes who can't be Yeah right dad turn
around I can't believe this is working
you just drop this key so I can pick up
the nose here nothing weird about what
I'm doing
Oh only one only one
[Music]
this has been the random horror reaction
compilation thanks for watching if you
like what you saw and you want to see
more why not subscribe to my channel
wanna help the channel grow please leave
a like add it to your favorites or share
it with your friends on Facebook and
Twitter thanks again and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]